foreign
[Music]
Los Angeles 2001 humble roots local kids
Street Racers who became hijacked
I graduated to high-speed smuggling
mobile jailbreaks Train Robbers
if it could be done in the car they did
it
it violates the laws of God and gravity
they did it twice
but the days were one man behind the
wheel of a car can make a difference are
over
it's time to prepare for what's coming
you might want to buckle up
I look out at this wonderful family I am
filled with so much pride
great Dome Toretto
the gun behind that wheel
I'd never be the man I am today and now
I am the man who's going to break your
family
Peace by peace
so Uncle Jacob your dad sent me
dummy I knew you would come for me I'm
Dante I'm Shantae so how about we all
just start shooting each other
for time to end this
[Applause]
let's take some Graves
you are not to be trusted are you in on
my Christmas list either
calvary's here it's showtime shoot tiny
tears Tommy tears no no we never agreed
on that
cheers
we need weapons
and cars
standing cars that was awesome do you
like surprises I adore them
how much time do we have four minutes
it'll have to do
I'd stayed down if I was you you'll need
to hit me harder for that
the game's over down
you lose
this is your last ride
Maybe This Is the End
you know what
I smell magic
they say when you're facing death your
life flashes before your eyes
are they right if this is the finish
line I'm not afraid
all right
[Music]